مساء الخير،
صدر كتاب الحقيقة الغائبة للشهيد فرج فودة سنة 1984،
الكتاب من  الحجم الصغير،
ويقع في 156 صحفة،
ولكنه من العيار الثقيل في محتواه.
جاء هذا الكتاب مقابل كتاب آخر،
كان له أثر كبير داخل الجماعات الإسلامية في الثمانينات،
وهو كتاب "الفريضة الغائبة" لأحد مؤسسي الجهاد الإسلامي في مصر،
المدعو محمد عبد السلام فرج،
والذي أعدم سنة 1982،
في قضية اغتيال الرئيس المصري محمد أنور السادات.
كتاب الفريضة الغائبة الذي صدر سنة 1980،
يقع في نفس الخط الفكري لكتاب في ظلال القرآن لسيد قطب،
يعتبر صاحبه أن القتال هو فرض عين على كل مسلم ومسلمة،
ويقول بأولوية قتال العدوّ القريب،
وهو الحاكم الكافر والمجتمع الجاهلي في العالم الإسلامي،
قبل قتال العدو البعيد وهو الإستعمار الصليبي الصهيوني.
فرج فودة في كتاب الحقيقة الغائبة،
سيعمل على دحض فكرة سيد قطب وعبد السلام فرج،
القائلة بجاهلية المجتمع المصري.
منذ فجر التاريخ،
استشرف المصرى القديم فكرة التوحيد على يد الفرعون «إخناتون»،
ووضع أركان فلسفة للإيمان على غاية من التجريد والروحانية،
وفكّر في لغز الموت وجعله محور حضارته المبكرة،
وشيد الأهرامات واكتشف التحنيط.
عُرف عن المصريين منذ العهد الفرعوني،
وصولا إلى الإسلام ومرورا باليهودية والمسيحية،
انهم شديدو التديّن.
قديما «الإسكندر الأكبر» لينال رضاء المصريين،
ذهب إلى «معبد آمون» وأعلن نفسه ابن الإله.
وحديثا «نابليون بونابرت» خلال حملته الشهيرة على مصر سنة 1798،
عرف ان الطريق إلى قلوب المصريين يمرّ عبر عقيدتهم،
وجاء على لسانه لكسبهم إلى جانبه ضد المماليك:
"لقد أخبروكم بأنني أتيت لأدمر دينكم، لا تصدقوهم،
بل جئت لاستعادة حقوقكم ومعاقبة المغتصبين،
كما أنني أحترم الله وأقدر الرسول والقرآن".
اذن التديّن مكوّن أساسي من مكوّنات الشخصية القاعدية المصرية.
يعتبر فرج فودة ان المجتمع المصري
هو أقرب المجتمعات لصحيح الإسلام،
حقيقة لا مظهرا، وعقيدة لا تمسكا بالشكليات.
ويتجلى ذلك في صدارة المصريين،
في مظاهر الاحتفال بالعقائد الدينية،
كالحج والصيام خلال شهر رمضان.
إلى جانب ان مصر تحتضن مؤسسة دينية،
من أكبر المؤسسات الدينية الإسلامية وهي جامع الأزهر.
اذن اسقاط حالة الجاهلية التي عاشتها شبه جزيرة العرب
على مصر اليوم،
هو من باب التعسّف الأيديولوجي،
ولا علاقة له بواقع المصريين.
ينطلق الإسلاميون في مقاربتهم لواقع المسلمين،
من هذه المسلّمة،
التي صاغها بذكاء المفكّر التنويري المغربي سعيد ناشيد
والقائلة؛
"إذا لم تكن لك حلول لمشاكل الناس،
فقل لهم الإسلام هو الحل،
لن يفهموك،
لكن لن يجرؤ احدا على الاعتراض".
لسوء حظ الإسلاميين تجرّأ فرج فودة على الإعتراض،
وطالبهم في كتابه الحقيقة الغائبة،
بتقديم برنامج سياسي عوض الشعارات العاطفية،
مثل "يا دولة الإسلام عودي"
أو "إسلامية إسلامية لا شرقية لا غربية."
كل الطيف الإسلامي،
من جماعة الإخوان المسلمين إلي تنظيم داعش
مرورا بتنظيم القاعدة وحزب التحرير والجهاد الإسلامي
ينادي بعودة الخلافة الإسلامية
وتطبيق الشريعة كحلّ وحيد وأوحد لإخراج الأمّة من الإنحطاط.
من القضايا التي بدأ فرج فودة في تناولها بالنقاش
في كتابه الحقيقة الغائبة،
قضية اختيار الحاكم في الإسلام،
فمن ضمن شروط إمام او خليفة المسلمين أن يكون قرشيًا،
ويستند "أهل السنة والحديث" إلى الحديث المنسوب للرسول،
والقائل إن أئمة المسلمين وخلفائهم يجب أن يكونوا من قريش،
وإنه لا يجب منازعتهم في هذا الأمر.
الحديث ورد في صحيحي البخاري ومسلم،
وكُتُب الحديث الأخرى في صيغ متعددة،
ففي صحيح البخاري ورد كالآتي؛
عن معاوية قال: قال رسول الله:
"إن هذا الأمر في قريش لا يعاديهم أحد
إلا أكبّه الله في النار على وجهه ما أقاموا الدين".
وفي صحيح مسلم ورد كما يلي:
"لا يزال الإسلام عزيزا بخلفاء كلهم من قريش".
وفي رواية عبد الله بن عمر، قال:
قال رسول الله:
"لا يزال هذا الأمر في قريش ما بقي منهم اثنان".
وقال رسول الله:
"الناس تبع لقريش في هذا الشأن،
مُسلمهم لمسلهم وكافرهم لكافرهم".
استنادا إلى هذا الحديث،
أجمع أهل السنة أن إمام المسلمين لا بد أن يكون قرشيا،
ويذكر أبو الحسن علي بن محمد الماوردي في كتاب "الأحكام السلطانية"؛
انه من شروط الإمام الأعظم،
أن يكون من قريش لورود النص فيه، وانعقاد الإجماع عليه.
من الواضح والجلي ان هذا الحديث وُضع لأسباب سياسية بعد وفاة الرسول،
ليبرر حكم القرشيين من الأمويين ثمّ من العباسيين،
ولو صحّت نسبة هذا الحديث للرسول
لما جادل الأنصار ابا بكر الصديق وعمر بن الخطاب وابا عبيدة الجرّاح
في امر خلافة الرسول في سقيفة بني ساعدة،
ولما تجرّؤوا على اختيار سعد بن عُبادة لتولّي الخلافة،
ويتساءل فرج فودة هنا،
كيف لدين جاء للعالمين،
ولا يُعطي فضلا لعربي على أعجمي إلا بالتقوى،
ان يقسم الناس إلى أصحاب دم أزرق؛ الحكام القرشيون،
وأصحاب دم أحمر؛ الأغلبية المحكومون؟
محاولات الملوك والحكام اثبات نسبهم القرشي الكاذب،
وانحدارهم من نسب الرسول عديدة عبر التاريخ،
ولا زالت متواصلة إلي اليوم،
يذكر فرج فودة محاولة الملك فاروق في مصر
عندما اراد ان يكون خليفة للمسلمين،
حيث اجتهد البعض من حاشيته في اثبات نسبه للرسول،
رغم ان الرجل ثابت ان جدّه لوالده هو محمد علي باشا الكبير وهو ألباني،
وجدّه لوالدته من أصول فرنسية هو سليمان باشا الفرنساوي،
الذي جاء لمصر مع الحملة الفرنسية واسمه الأصلي Joseph Sève.
ثمّ يواصل فرج فودة في منهجه التفكيكي
لمقولات الإسلاميين المتعلقة بالخلافة،
ويبيّن ان القرآن والأحاديث النبوية لا تتضمّن احكاما  شرعية في شأن الخلافة،
والخلافة الإسلامية تمّت عبر التاريخ بسِتَّة طرق مختلفة؛
فاصبح ابو بكر الصديق أول خليفة للمسلمين بعد اجتماع السقيفة،
ورفض زعيم الأنصار سعد بن عُبادة مبايعته،
وكذلك علي بن ابي طالب،
الذي تقول بعض الروايات انه بايع ابا بكر بعد ايام،
في حين تقول روايات أخرى انه بايعه بعد شهور،
إثر وفاة زوجته فاطمة.
ثم تولّى عمر بن الخطاب خلافة المسلمين
بكتاب مغلق من ابي بكر أوصى فيه بالخلافة لعمر،
وبايع عليه المسلمون دون أن يعلموا ما فيه.
اما الخليفة الثالث عثمان بن عفان،
فتم اختياره خليفة من طرف ستة صحابة
عيّنهم عمر بن الخطاب وهو على فراش الموت وهم؛
عثمان نفسه،
وعلي بن ابي طالب،
وطلحة بن عبيد الله،
والزبير بن العوام،
وعبد الرحمان بن عوف،
وسعد بن ابي الوقاص،
أمّا علي بن طالب فقد تولّى الخلافة بعد مقتل عثمان
بعد ان بايعه اهل المدينة وبعض الأمصار،
ورفضت عائشة ام المؤمنين وبعض الصحابة مبايعته.
امّا معاوية بن أبي سفيان فقد تولّى الخلافة بحدّ السيف
بعد معارك دامية خاضها ضد علي بن أبي طالب.
واخيرا تولّى ابنه يزيد الخلافة بالوارثة،
وامر بقطع رأس الحسين بن علي حفيد الرسول عندما تمرّد على حكمه.
اذن من أبي بكر الصديق إلى يزيد بن معاوية بن ابي سفيان،
توجد ستة أشكال مختلفة لإختيار حاكم للمسلمين،
هنا،
يسائل فرج فودة دعاة الخلافة الإسلامية،
اي شكل من هذه الأشكال الستة لإختيار الحاكم
سيكون اكثر نجاعة من الديمقراطية العلمانية
القائمة على الإنتخاب الحرّ والمباشر لكل المواطنيين؟
ثمّ يواصل فرج فودة في كتابه الحقيقة الغائبة
حشرالإسلاميين في الزاوية،
عندما يشرع في تفكيك مفهومين مركزيين في أطروحاتهم،
الأوّل،
هو ان تطبيق الشريعة الإسلامية هو الحل السحري لكل مشاكل الأمّة،
والثاني،
أن الخلافة الإسلامية الراشدة كانت نموذجا مثاليا للحكم.
دأبت كتب التراث على تجميل فترة الخلافة الراشدة،
وتصوير الخلفاء والصحابة والتابعين
على أنهم ملائكة وقدّيسين،
والحال انهم بشر،
تصارعوا وتقاتلوا من أجل كرسي الحكم،
و تسببوا في فتن بين المسلمين،
الحقيقة التي سيسردها فرج فودة حول هذه الفترة
هي الحقيقة الغائبة او بالأحرى المُغيبة على أذهان المسلمين،
وما سيذكره الدكتور فرج فودة في كتابه الحقيقة الغائبة،
استمدّه من كتب كبار المؤرخين المسلمين،
مثل ابن اسحاق
والواقدي
والطبري
والمسعودي
وابن الأثير
وابن كثير
والسيوطي
وابن خلدون
وغيرهم...
وكل ما اورده فرج فودة اورده كذلك مفكّرون وكتّاب معاصرين كبار،
اورده طه حسين في كتابه الفتنة الكبرى،
واورده المفكّر التونسي هشام جعيّط في كتابه الفتنة،
ومحمد عابد الجابري في كتابه نقد العقل العربي
وغيرهم...
فقط،
ان فرج فودة،
ليس مفكّرا أكاديميا مثل هؤلاء وهو لا يدّعي ذلك،
يقول الرجل في مقدمة كتابه:
"هذا حديث تاريخ لا يزعم صاحبه أنه متخصص فيه،
أو فارس في ميدانه،
لكنه يزعم أنه قارئ له في أناة،
محلل له في صبر،
موثق له في دقة،
ناقد له في منطق..."
ثمّ يُضيف:
"هذا حديث تاريخ وسياسة وفكر
وليس حديث دين وإيمان وعقيدة،
وحديث مسلمين لا حديث إسلام".
الإضافة النوعية لفرج فودة في كتابه،
هي انّه تجرّأ على إنزال الحقيقة
الغائبة والمُغيبة في التاريخ الإسلامي
من برجها العاجي الأكاديمي
لتصبح في متناول عامة الناس،
هذه الأفكار لم تعد شأنا نخبويا
بل تحوّلت إلي أفكار مقاتلة في الفضاء العام،
وهذا اكثر ما ازعج سدنة معبد التراث.
دامت الخلافة الراشدة أي فترة حكم الخلفاء الراشدين حوالي ثلاثين عاما،
بالتحديد تسعة وعشرين عاما وخمسة أشهر،
بدأت بخلافة أبي بكر الصديق ودامت سنتين وثلاثة أشهر وثمانية أيام،
ثمّ خلافة عمر بن الخطاب ودامت عشر سنين وستة أشهر وتسعة عشر يوما،
ثم خلافة عثمان بن عفان ودامت إحدى عشرة سنة واحد عشر شهرا وتسعة عشر يوما،
ثم خلافة علي بن ابي طالب ودامت أربع سنين وسبعة أشهر.
كانت مدة خلافة أبي بكر الصديق قصيرة نسبيا،
حوالي سنتين وثلاثة أشهر،
واجه فيها أول حرب أهلية شهدتها دولة الإسلام الناشئة،
والتي تعرف بحروب الردّة،
والتي أثبتت بحوث المؤرخين المعاصرين
ان الرواية التقليدية التراثية حول هذه الحروب لم تكن دقيقة.
حروب الردة لم تكن حروبا ضد أناس ارتدوا عن الإسلام
بل كانت في الأساس حروبا سياسية لإخماد تمرّد على سلطة المدينة،
لإخضاع من لم يخضع بعد من العرب.
بعد وفاة الرسول،
اعتبرت بعض القبائل ان دفع الزكاة لأبي بكر كرها هو اذلال لها،
وان اتفاقها مع النبي لدفع الزكاة كان اتفاقا مع شخص النبي،
وليس مع قريش التي استولت على الحكم بعد وفاة الرسول.
هذه القبائل لم تترك الإسلام،
وكانت ترغب في التفاوض على اتفاق جديد مع الخليفة أبي بكر،
لكنه رفض ذلك وأصر على تطبيق الاتفاقات المبرمة مع النبي كاملة.
ولو كان سبب حروب الردّة عقائديا لما اختلف عمر بن الخطاب مع ابي بكر الصديق،
عندما سأله مستنكرًا عن قتل الناطقين بالشهادتين
وأن المسلم لا يُقتل إلا لثلاث (إن زنى أو ارتد أو قصاصًا لقتل)،
فأجاب أبو بكر بأن للشهادة حقها.
ويستنتج فرج فودة اننا هنا أمام اجتهادٍ لأبي بكر قد يخطئ، وقد يصيب.
وإن كان اجتهاد ابي بكر ملزمًا اليوم
لوجب قتل جميع المسلمين لأن لا أحد منهم يُخرج الزكاة للدولة
بل يُخرجوها للمحتاجين مباشرة.
المسلم اليوم لا يدفع  الزكاة للدولة بل يدفع الضرائب.
سياسيا،
سلوك الخليفة ابي بكر الصديق في زمنه سلوك قويم،
فهو تصرّف كرجل دولة ناشئة،
وعليه ان يحافظ على وحدتها بالقوّة،
بإعتبار ان الدولة في مفهومها القديم والمعاصر
هي الكيان الوحيد في المجتمع الذي يحتكر العنف،
لكن لا يمكن بأي حال من الأحوال ان نبرر سلوك أبي بكر الصديق دينيا،
لانه في ما يسمّى بحروب الردّة أغلب القبائل العربية
تمرّدت على سلطة المدينة كسلطة سياسية
ولم تتمرّد على الإسلام كدين وعقيدة.
يستنتج فرج فودة،
ان قرار ابي بكر الصديق في حروب الردّة،
كان قرارا سياسيا مدنيا وليس قرارا دينيا.
بعد ذلك يمرّ الدكتور فرج فودة
لتشريح فترة حكم الخليفة عمر بن الخطاب،
التي دامت عشر سنين وستة أشهر وتسعة عشر يوما،
لا يخفي فرج فودة اعجابه بشخصية عمر بن الخطاب
في ادارة شؤون المسلمين.
فعمر بن الخطّاب هو من ألغى سهم المؤلفة قلوبهم من الزكاة،
وأوقف حكمًا قد استقر أيام الرسول وفي جزء من عهد أبي بكر،
لأنه رأى أن الإسلام صار قويًا ولا حاجة لتأليف القلوب.
وقام عمر بن الخطّاب كذلك في فترة حكمه بتعطيل حدّ السرقة
في عام مجاعة والمعروف بعام الرمادة.
وكذلك نسخ الخليفة عمر بن الخطاب،
حكم الآية المتعلّقة بالفيء،
ورفض تقسيم الأراضي المفتوحة على الصحابة والمسلمين
لضمان حقوق الأجيال القادمة.
وألزم عمر كبار الصحابة بالبقاء في المدينة،
ومنعهم من مغادرتها إلا بإذنه،
وأجرى عليهم ارزاقا محددة،
وبرّر لهم ذلك بأنه يُحب ان يستأنس بهم ويهتدي بمشورتهم،
وهو في الحقيقة خشي ان يفتتن الناس بهم،
ففرض عليهم اقامة جبرية ناعمة في المدينة.
كما تجرّأ عمر بن الخطاب اثناء فترة خلافته
على عزل اكبر قائد عسكري في تاريخ الإسلام والمسلمين،
وهو خالد بن الوليد،
لأنّه لم ينس له فعله الشنيع في السنة الحادية عشرة للهجرة،
عندما قتل خلال حروب الردّة الصحابي مالكا بن نويرة،
من كبار بني يربوع من بني تميم،
وقطع رأسه وجعله ثالثة الأثافي،
ووضع عليه قدر طعامه،
ودخل في نفس الليلة بزوجته ليلى أم تميم.
يستنتج فرج فودة حقيقتين هامتين من خلال سيرة عمر بن الخطاب؛
أولاهما،
ان الرجل استخدم عقله في التحليل و التعليل،
ولم يقف عند ظاهر النص،
وثانيهما،
انه طبّق روح الإسلام وجوهره مدركا ان العدل غاية النص،
وان مخالفة النص من اجل العدل،
أصح في ميزان الإسلام الصحيح من مجافاة العدل بالتزام النص.
ثمّ ينتقل فرج فودة للحديث عن فترة حكم الخليفة الثالث عثمان بن عفّان،
التي امتدّت إحدى عشرة سنة واحد عشر شهرا وتسعة عشر يوما،
وشهدت تدفق ثروات كبيرة على بيت مال المسلمين
بعد ان تحولت الخلافة الإسلامية إلى إمبراطورية مترامية الأطراف،
واصبحت الغنائم هي المحرّك الأساسي للفتوحات،
واذا كانت السمة الرئيسية لخلافة عمر بن الخطاب هي التقشّف،
كانت السمة الرئيسية لخلافة عثمان هي البذخ.
على عكس عمر سمح عثمان للصحابة بمغادرة المدينة،
لينتشروا في الأمصار المفتوحة،
واغدق عليهم بالعطايا والمساعدات من بيت مال المسلمين،
وتكونت ثروات ضخمة عنده وعند أقاربه من بني أميّة وعند الصحابة،
يقول المفكّر التونسي هشام جعيّط في كتابه الفتنة متحدثا عن ثروة عثمان بن عفان:
" فالبيت الذي ابتناه عثمان كان من الحجر والخشب الثمين.
وكوّن لنفسه قطعانا واملاكا في المدينة.
وعند وفاته، حسب رواية المسعودي،
كانت امواله الشخصية قد وصلت إلى 150.000 دينار ومليون درهم،
واما امواله غير المنقولة في وادي القرى وحُنين وسواهما فقد كانت تساوي  100.000 دينار.
وترك أيضا عددا من الجياد والجِمال.
ويذكر ابن سعد مبلغ 25 مليون ونصف المليون درهم
وُجدت عند وفاته لدى خازنه، ونُهبت."
ويذكر ابن سعد في كتاب الطبقات كذلك،
ان الصحابيين طلحة بن عبيد الله والزيبر بن العوام المبشرين بالجنّة
كانا من اكثر الصحابة ثراء ونعمة،
وقدّرت ثروة طلحة عند وفاته بحوالي ثلاثين مليون درهم،
اما عبد الرحمان بن عوف وهو بدوره من المبشرين بالجنة،
فقد ترك بعد وفاته وفق رواية بن سعد دائما؛
الف جمل،
وثلاثة الاف رأس غنم،
ومئة حصان،
وسبائك ذهب تُكسر بالفأس.
أُتهم عثمان بن عفان بالمحاباة و المحسوبية
بعد ان اغدق العطايا من بين مال المسلمين بشكل غير شرعي
على اهله واقاربه،
فقد اعطى لمروان بن الحكم ابن عمه خُمس غنائم افريقية،
ومنح صدقات قُضاعة لعمّه الحكم،
واعطى الحارث بن الحكم 200.000 درهم،
وزيد بن ثابت 100.000 درهم،
وهو نفسه استدان مبلغ 500.000 درهم من بيت مال المسلمين،
وتأخّر او امتنع عن تسديده،
عودوا الى كتاب الفتنة للمفكر التونسي هشام جعيط الصفحة 63،
وستجدون كل المصادر حول هذه الأرقام
كما وردت عند ابن سعد والمسعودي والبلاذري والطبري،
وهي نفس الأرقام و المراجع التي اوردها الدكتور فرج فودة في كتابه الحقيقة الغائبة،
وطه حسين في كتابه الفتنة الكبرى.
منذ بداية خلافته،
بدا واضحا وجليا،
ان عثمان كان يرغب في السيطرة على مفاصل الحكم بتعيين اقاربه،
فعيّن شقيقه الوليد بن عقبة عاملا على الكوفة
بدلا من الصحابي المبشّر بالجنة سعد بن ابي الوقاص،
وعين أخاه بالرضاعة عبد الله بن سعد ابن ابي سرح
عاملا على مصر محل عمرو ابن العاص،
ولعبد الله بن سعد بن ابي سرح حادثة خطيرة مع الرسول،
فقد كان احد كتبة الوحي ثم ارتد عن الإسلام وعاد إلى مكة،
وادّعى ان  النبي أملى عليه
(إن الله كان سميعاً عليماً)،
وكتبها هوّ (إن الله كان عليماً حكيماً)،
وعندما قرأها على النبي وافق على كتابتها دون اعتراض.
عبد الله بن ابي السرح كان ضمن قائمة من 11 شخص،
أهدر النبي دمهم عند دخوله لمكة ولو وجودوا مُتعلقين بأستار الكعبة،
ولكن النبي عفى عنه بتدخل من أخيه في الرضاعة عثمان بن عفّان.
تنامى غضب المسلمين في الأمصار خاصة في البصرة والكوفة و مصر
ضد سياسة عثمان بن عفان،
وقرروا الزحف على المدينة عاصمة الخلافة لإجباره على التخلي عن الحكم،
لكن عثمان سيرفض رفضا مطلقا التخلي عن الخلافة،
وسيردد مقولته الشهيرة؛
"لن انزع سربالا سربلنيه الله"،
(السربال هو القميص)،
اي ان خلافته هي هبة من الله،
ولا يمكنه التنحّي ولا يجوز تنحيته.
الثوار سيحاصرون دار عثمان بن عفان اربعين يوما،
وسيُمنع من إمامة الصلاة ويطرد بالحجارة من المسجد،
وسيمنع عنه الماء،
وسيتخلّى عنه تدريجيا كل الصحابة تقريبا،
طلحة الذي كان يطمع في الخلافة،
سيشارك في الحصار ويدفع افراد عشيرته تيم للإنضمام للمتمردين،
بقية الصحابة وعلى رأسهم علي بن ابي طالب،
سيقفون على الحياد ويتركون عثمان يواجه مصيره وحيدا،
لأنه نكث الوعد الذي قطعه لإصلاح نفسه كما ذكر الطبري،
امّا عائشة أم المؤمنين فكانت تُخرج قميص الرسول وتقول:
هذا ثوب رسول الله لم يَبْلَ وعثمان قد ابلى سنته،
و كانت تحرّض المسلمين  على قتله،
قائلة: "أقتلوا نعثلا قد كفر."
يذكر ابن الأثير في (النهاية)، وابن منظور في (لسان العرب):
أعداء عثمان يسمّونه نعثلاً،
تشبيهاً برجل من مصر، كان طويل اللحية اسمه نعثل،
وقيل: النعثل: الشيخ الأحمق، وذكر الضباع.
كذلك معاوية بن ابي سفيان ولحسابات سياسية
لم يسارع ببعث جيش من دمشق لنجدة الخليفة المحاصر.
انتهى الحصار بقتل الخليفة الثالث عثمان بن عفان
بشكل عنيف و مأساوي على يد الثوار
الذين قدموا من مصر والكوفة والبصرة وجزء من أهل المدينة،
وشارك محمد بن ابي بكر الصديق في اهانته وقتله.
ولم يستطع أهله دفنه طيلة يومين،
ورفض المسلمون الصلاة عليه،
ورُمي جثمانه بالحجارة،
ولم يدفن في مقبرة المسلمين بل دُفن في حَشّ كوكب،
وهو بستان لشخص يهودي يُدعى كوكب،
قبل ان يضمّه في ما بعد معاوية بن ابي سفيان
إلى مقبرة البقيع الخاصة بالمسلمين.
يروي الطبري في تاريخه:
"لبث عثمان بعدما قتل ليلتين لا يستطيعون دفنه،
ثمّ حمله أربعة،
فلمّا وُضع ليُصلّى عليه جاء نفر من الأنصار يمنعونهم الصلاة عليه،
فيهم أسلم بن أوس بن بجرة الساعدي وأبو حية المازني في عدّة ومنعوهم أن يدفن بالبقيع،
فقال أبو جهم: ادفنوه...
فقالوا: لا والله لا يدفن في مقابر المسلمين أبداً،
فدفنوه في حَشّ كوكب،
فلمّا ملكت بنو اُمية أدخلوا ذلك الحَشّ في البقيع
فهو اليوم مقبرة بني أمية."
النهاية المأساوية للخليفة الثالث عثمان بن عفان،
دفعت الدكتور فرج فودة إلى التساؤلات التالية:
ألم يكن عثمان من خيار الصحابة؟
وأعلاهم تمسكًا بالعقيدة، ومن المبشرين بالجنة؟
ويُلقّب بذو النورين لأنها تزوّج ببنتي الرسول؟
ألم تكن الشريعة الإسلامية مطبقة؟
الجواب؛
بلى.
لكن هل ترتب على ذلك صلاح حال الرعية وتحقق العدل والأمن؟
الجواب؛
لا.
بعد عثمان بن عفان، نمرّ مع الدكتور فرج فودة،
لتفكيك الخلافة الراشدة في عهد علي بن ابي طالب،
والتي دامت فترة حكمه أربع سنين وسبعة أشهر.
توافد بعد مقتل عثمان اهل المدينة وخاصة الأنصار منهم
لمبايعة علي وتقليده الخلافة،
لكن شرعية علي بن ابي طالب ستكون مبتورة،
بسبب رفض اغلب الصحابة وام المؤمنين عائشة مبايعته.
سينجح علي في نيل إعتراف الأمصار الرئيسية للخلافة،
وهي البصرة والكوفة ومصر.
ولكن في المقابل سينشأ تيار معارض يطالب بالثأر لدم عثمان سيرفض مبايعته،
هذا التيار سيتزعمه في الشام معاوية بن ابي سفيان،
الذي يقال انه وضع فوق منبر الجامع الكبير في دمشق قميص عثمان الملطّخ بالدم،
يبكيه كل يوم ستون الف شيخ،
وستتزعم هذا التيار في مكّة عائشة أرملة النبي وأم المؤمنين
وإثنان من الصحابة المبشرين بالجنة وهما طلحة والزبير،
رغم ان ثلاثتهم كانوا ضد عثمان بل حرّضوا على قتله،
ولكنّهم اتفقوا على رفضهم المطلق لتولي علي بن ابي طالب خلافة المسلمين.
سنة 36 هجرية، ستدور أول معركة بين جيش علي بن ابي طالب من جهة،
وجيش عائشة والزبير وطلحة  في البصرة من جهة أخرى.
ساند اهل البصرة  في هذه المعركة عائشة وطلحة والزبير،
في حين ساند أهل الكوفة عليا،
وسميت هذه المعركة بمعركة الجمل،
لان عائشة ام المؤمنين كانت في قلب المعركة على جملها جالسة في هودج مدرّع بالحديد،
وكان جمل عائشة هو النقطة الحامية في المعركة
كما قال المؤرخ التونسي هشام جعيط.
انتهت هذه  المعركة الدموية بقطع عرقوب الجمل
ووضع هودجها المقدّس جانبا
وسط حوالي عشرة آلاف قتيل موزعين بالتساوي بين المعسكرين،
الذين كانا قد ضمّا خمسين الف مقاتل،
ومن بين قتلى معركة الجمل،
الصحابيين المبشرين بالجنة، طلحة والزبير.
بعد حوالي سنة من معركة الجمل، سنة 37 هجرية،
سيواجه علي بن ابي طالب معاوية بن ابي سفيان في صفّين.
كان معاوية يرى أنه ولى دم عثمان،
وأنه لا بدّ من الأخذ بثأره من القتلة اللذين إحتضنهم علي،
مستشهدا بالآية 33 من سورة الإسراء والقائلة:
وَمَنْ قُتِلَ مَظْلُومًا فَقَدْ جَعَلْنَا لِوَلِيِّهِ سُلْطَانًا فَلا يُسْرِفْ فِى القَتْلِ إِنَّهُ كَانَ منصورًا.
شهدت
وقعة صفّين
التي سمّاها المؤرخ والمفكّر التونسي هشام جعيط بإلياذة العرب،
اكبر حشد عسكري عربي في التاريخ،
ستون الف مقاتل من كل جانب،
مصحوبين بأطفال وشيوخ وخدم ونساء،
كانوا جمهورا للمعركة لا يقل عن مئتي الف شخص.
ولمّا،
رأى عمرو بن العاص احد قادة جيش معاوية،
تقدّم جيش علي على عدة محاور قام بخدعة،
حيث دعا جنوده إلى رفع المصاحف على أسنّة الرماح،
ودعوة جنود علي لجعل القرآن حكما بينهم،
وبالفعل نجحت خدعته، وتوقف القتال،
وقبل علي بالتحكيم.
قُتل من الطرفين خلال هذه المعركة،
بحسب الروايات التاريخية، وبخاصة تاريخ الطبري،
سبعون ألفاً،
خمسة وأربعون ألفاً من جيش معاوية، وخمسة وعشرون ألفاً من جيش علي.
قبول علي بن ابي طالب بالتحكيم
سيؤدي إلي انشقاق في جيشه وظهور فرقة الخوارج،
الذين سيقوم بإبادتهم في معركة النهروان،
لكن أحد الناجين منهم في هذه المعركة ويُدعى عبد الرحمن بن ملجم
سيغتال علي بن ابي طالب في مسجد الكوفة الكبير في 21 رمضان سنة 40 هـ.
يستنتج الدكتور فرج فودة
ان عليا بن ابي طالب كان الحاكم الصالح في الزمن الخطأ،
وانتصر معاوية وآلت إليه الخلافة في ما بعد،
لأنه رجل دنيا في حين ان علي كان رجل دين،
وكان حازما حتى مع اقرب الناس اليه،
ويورد الدكتور فرج فودة،
حادثة وقعت لعلي بن ابي طالب مع ابن عمّه عبد الله بن العباس،
وهو من اكبر رواة الحديث ويعتبره التراث الإسلامي حبر الأمّة وبحرها.
كان عبد الله بن عباس واليا على البصرة،
وكان ابو الأسود الدؤلي صاحب بيت مال المسلمين هناك،
فبعث هذا الأخير برسالة لعلي بن ابي طالب يقول له فيها:
"ان عاملك وابن عمك قد أكل ما تحت يده بغير علمك"،
اي انه استولى على اموال بيت مال المسلمين،
فكتب علي لابن عمه عبد الله بن عبّاس مستفسرا ما يلي:
"أما بعد، فقد بلغني عنك أمر،
إن كنت فعلته فقد أسخطت ربّك،
وأخربت أمانتك،
وعصيت إمامك،
وخنت المسلمين؛
بلغني انك جردت الأرض وأكلت ما تحت يديك،
فارفع إليّ  حسابك واعلم ان حساب الله أشد من حساب الناس."
فرد ابن عباس على علي برسالة كتب فيها ما يلي:
" والله لأَنْ ألقَى الله بما في بطن هذه الأرض من عقيانها
وبطِلاع ما على ظهرها
أحبُّ إليَّ من أن ألقاه وقد سفكتُ دماء الأمة لأنال المُلك والإمارة،
فابعث إلى عملك من أحببت".
استقال عبد الله بن العباس من منصبه،
وجمع ما تبقّى من مال في بيت مال المسلمين،
ومضى ليستقر في البيت الحرام،
ولما كتب إليه علي مرّة أخرى يطلب منه ردّ الأمانة،
أجاب ابن عباس:
إن حقي في بيت المال لأعظم مما أخذتُ منه،
ثم يهدد الخليفة قائلًا:
"لئن لم تدعني من أساطيرك لأحملنَّ هذا المال إلى معاوية يقاتلك به"
( انظر تاريخ الطبري ج4)
هذا غيض من فيض ممّا حدث في الخلافة الراشدة،
بعيدا عن الصورة المثالية والرومانسية
التي يروجها دعاة الخلافة حول هذه الفترة؛
ثلاثة من الخلفاء الراشدين الأربعة تم اغتيالهم.
المبشران بالجنّة طلحة والزبير حرّضا على قتل مبشّرا آخر بالجنّة وهو عثمان بن عفان،
ثم خاضا حربا ضد مبشّر آخر بالجنّة
وهو علي بن ابي طالب، وقتلا في هذه الحرب.
عثمان بن عفان المبشر بالجنة مات مقتولا
ولم يصلّ عليه ولم يُدفن في مقبرة المسلمين.
الصحابة والتابعون تقاتلوا من اجل كرسي الحكم ومتاع الدنيا،
وتسببوا في سفك دماء عشرات الآف من المسلمين.
عبد الله بن العباس حبر الأمة وبحرها،
والذي سيؤسس احفاده الخلافة العباسية في ما بعد
اختلس اموال بيت مال المسلمين بالبصرة.
الغريب في الأمر،
ان كل هذه المآسي،
سوف تحاول السردية الإسلامية الرسمية
ان تُحمّل مسؤوليتها لشخصية يهودية أسطورية وهمية،
اسمها
عبد الله بن سبأ.
اتوقف عند هذا الحد،
لأعود لكم
في الحلقة القادمة،
على قناة أنا أفكر إذن أنا موجود،
لتناول الحقيقة الغائبة
في الخلافتين الأموية و العباسية
كما سردها المفكّر الشهيد فرج فودة،
وستطلعون على حقائق ﻳﺸﻴﺐ ﻟﻬﺎ ﺍﻟﻮﻟﺪﺍﻥ.
هذا نجيب البكوشي من باريس،
أشكركم جزيل الشكر على المتابعة وعلى دعمكم للقناة،
أوصيكم خيرا بعقولكم،
وإلى اللقاء.